From brutal Gorr the God Butcher scenes, to
Thor dancing to ABBA and the return of the
Grandmaster, there's a stack of deleted scenes
and characters in Thor Love and Thunder!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing [and explaining]
every scene and character Marvel cut from
the fourth Thor movie.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Christian Bale's Gorr is a creepy, menacing
new antagonist in the MCU, though his presence
can feel a little lacking in screen time.
And in fact, numerous Gorr scenes were filmed
that didn't make the final cut.
For example, Bale described a horrifying scene
where Gorr, after taking possession of the
Necrosword, cuts away the tattoos on his head
and body that were symbols of his religion.
The deleted scene would have explained the
reason for the scars we see on him later in
the movie, but it was removed as it was deemed
too extreme for a family-friendly film.
This shot of Gorr picking up the sword on
a beach which was in the trailers but not
the final movie could be from that moment.
Bale has also revealed numerous actors he
filmed scenes with that didn't make it into
the final film.
I got to work with Peter Dinklage.
Dinklage played Eitri who last appeared in
Avengers: Infinity War when Thor came to his
home to ask for a weapon that could kill Thanos.
That was Stormbreaker, and I suspect the reason
Gorr went to visit Eitri was because the villain
needed Stormbreaker to open a portal so he
could reach Eternity.
In the cut scene, Eitri may have been unwilling
or unable to create the weapon again, likely
leading Gorr to kill him.
This would have been quite a sad moment as
Eitri was the last of his kind with Thanos
already having massacred the rest of his people.
300 dwarves lived on this ring.
I made what he wanted.
Then he killed everyone anyway.
A scene of Gorr killing Eitri might well have
been hard for fans to stomach;
however, it would certainly have helped beef
up Gorr's screen time and the reasons for
his nickname, the Butcher.
And it also looks like Gorr encountered the
Grandmaster from Thor: Ragnarok in the original
cut of the movie as well.
I got to work with Jeff Goldblum.
He's not in the final film either.
The last time we saw the Grandmaster was in
a Ragnarok post-credit scene on Sakaar where
he was attempting to bargain with the rebels
who'd risen up against him.
I just gotta say, I'm proud of you all.
This revolution has been a huge success.
Yay us!
I think it might have been curious to see
how that revolution had panned out for the
Grandmaster, and whether he'd somehow managed
to charm his way out of a very sticky situation.
I suspect Gorr might have decided to kill
him - even though he's not a god - for his
tyrannical rule on Sakaar.
Doesn't that sound good?
Again, as with Eitri, showing more of Gorr
could have really built up Bale's villain
even further than in the final film.
A scene I think a lot of fans wish had been
included was seeing Jane's original transformation
into the Mighty Thor.
Footage from the New Asgard set shows there
was a scene filmed with a dummy and puppeteer
where Jane was floating in the air and convulsing
right next to the spot where the broken pieces
of Mjolnir were on display.
In the final movie, we do see Jane visiting
the spot and the pieces of the hammer activating,
but we never got to see what happened next,
which presumably involved the hammer re-forming
itself and Jane becoming Thor for the first
time.
Before Russell Crowe became the egotistical
and decadent god Zeus, it appears he was originally
going to play Satan in the movie.
A Marvel concept artist has revealed he was
commissioned to create a "comedic" look for
Crowe as Satan.
According to the artist, this version of the
devil was meant to be "humourously debauched"
similar to Zeus in the final movie who was
more concerned with his own pleasures than
helping Thor against Gorr.
The devil almost making his first appearance
in the MCU will undoubtedly add fuel to all
the Mephisto theories that have spawned since
WandaVision.
Natalie Portman has also revealed there were
tons of scenes involving Jane that didn't
make the final cut and said there's a "missing
period in the film" where we would have seen
how Jane and Valkyrie got to know each other
and became close.
Although Jane dies and goes to Valhalla at
the end of the movie, given the rumours of
a potential Mighty Thor spin-off and how Valkyrie
said to Jane she missed fighting with her
sisters and that she also hoped to go to Valhalla
one day herself, I could see these two teaming
up in the future.
And it looks like Thor originally spent more
time with the Guardians of the Galaxy at the
beginning of the movie.
This cut scene plays up the idea that Thor
just didn't really want to fight any more
as the Guardians charge into battle while
he just turns around and walks away with a
resigned air about him.
And Thor's deleted voiceover from the first
teaser trailer confirms that, in the original
movie, he was initially done with trying to
be a hero any more.
These hands were once used for battle.
Now they're but humble tools for peace.
I need to figure out exactly who I am.
My superheroing days are over.
A brand new character played by Lena Headey,
perhaps best known to many as Cersei from
Game of Thrones, appeared in scenes filmed
for Thor Love and Thunder which didn't make
it to the final cut.
Possible parts she could have played were
an Olympian God, Gorr's wife, or perhaps Valkyrie's
romantic interest given that at Comic Con,
Tessa Thompson said "as new king of Asgard",
Valkyrie's first order of business would be
to find her queen.
Whether Valkyrie's Queen was in the original
script or it was just Thompson's thoughts
about her character at the time, isn't quite
clear at the moment.
Chris Hemsworth revealed in an interview that
there was "a full dance scene" of him that
didn't make it into the final movie, and it
was set to ABBA's "Waterloo".
It also involved Thor "shooting lightning
out of his fingertips" and it could have been
a fun moment, perhaps with shades of Star
Lord's dance-off in the first Guardians movie
mixed with Shazam's "Lightning From My Hands"
scene.
Christian Bale has revealed his original request
for taking the part was that he be allowed
to reference Aphex Twin's "Come To Daddy"
music video.
The video has many unsettling elements, and
Bale wanted to emulate a character that emerges
from a TV set and performs a horrifying scream.
Bale says they did film that moment, but he
understands that it was probably too scary
for a PG-13 movie and said it "might have
had people running for the exits".
Gorr was also going to have a dance during
his final battle with Thor when he felt like
he was about to win, and the scene would have
taken inspiration from Aphex Twin's "Windowlicker"
and was also supposed to mirror Thor's earlier
ABBA dance.
By the sounds of it, it was going to be too
scary or dark as well because in another interview
Bale also said there was a lot more "creepy
as hell stuff, but that was perhaps pushing
it to a realm where maybe it wouldn't have
been able to be family friendly".
Marvel are well-known for modifying trailer
scenes to remove potential spoilers before
a movie's released.
We saw how Thor's missing eye was restored
for the Ragnarok trailers, and there's a subtle
change in the Love and Thunder trailers made
to Miek's whiteboard to avoid revealing spoilers.
When Thor gives his rousing speech to the
Asgardians…
Times like this, we need to unite, come together.
I'm sorry.
Miek, it's very hard to give a rousing speech
with the [screech sound] noise.
…what Miek has written on the whiteboard
in the trailer is basically what's just been
happening in that scene.
In the final film, however, it's completely
different as the whiteboard has a mass of
drawings that reveal a huge amount of the
movie's plot;
from Gorr's opening scene to the Guardians
fighting;
then the gift of the screaming goats;
Sif losing an arm;
King Valkyrie dreaming of fighting;
Shadow Realm monsters;
and even Eternity.
The screaming goats are a running gag in the
movie, though fans are divided on whether
they like them or not.
And according to Tessa Thompson – who's
previously said that she's obsessed with goats
– she filmed a scene where Valkyrie had
a conversation with the screaming creatures,
but it didn't make it into the final cut.
Giant goats!
Oh, look at those!
They are wonderful.
They also scream quite a lot.
There's also some clips in the trailers of
deleted Valkyrie scenes, like this one where
she's licking her sword during the battle
in Omnipotence City.
And there's another deleted moment of her
bored out of her mind as King Valkyrie, although
a slightly different version where she's twiddling
one of her daggers did make it in to the final
cut.
Although these were just tiny deleted moments,
I do wish there'd been a bit more Valkyrie
in the final film, and less Korg.
In Ragnarok, he was fine as comic relief in
a few scenes, but in Love and Thunder, it
felt like he was in too much of the movie
and his jokes often didn't land for me, though,
of course, comedy is very subjective.
There were also some more emotional scenes
between Jane and Thor removed from the final
cut.
And Portman has also said there were "20 different
versions of [one key scene]".
As you see, lots of stuff ends up on the cutting
room floor, even though it is brilliant, beautiful
stuff.
Portman also revealed that there are "whole
sequences, planets, characters, and worlds
that didn't end up in the movie".
The trailers do have some deleted shots of
Valkyrie together with Thor on a planet with
what looks like a lot of trash behind them
which might mean they went back to Sakaar
at some point.
Of course, with all of these deleted scenes,
a lot of fans will be asking for The Waititi
Cut, which apparently was initially four hours
long, versus the final cut of just under two
hours.
Now, this 4-hour cut was never an actual watchable
movie, it's what's known as the assembly cut
which is all of the main footage which might
make it into the final film before the director
and editor begin trimming it down.
In fact, as much as I wish some things had
been in the final movie like Jane's Mighty
Thor transformation, more Valkyrie and more
Gorr, it's essential for any movie to trim
the fat and cut out unnecessary subplots.
So, do you think Love and Thunder did a good
job of doing that?
Or did it feel "like [they] asked a bunch
of 10 year olds what should be in a movie
and just said yes to everything", which is
what Taika Waititi said himself it felt like
when they were developing the film?
It's always fascinating to know why things
make it into a movie and what gets cut out
for better or worse, and if you'd like to
discover the horrific original opening scene
of Scarlet Witch murdering Mordo in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness, tap
here for everything that was deleted from
that movie.
There's also a link in the video description.
So, how do you rate Thor Love and Thunder?
And do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been in the final movie?
Let me know in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this video, do leave a
thumbs-up, I really appreciate it.
Tap left for my full Marvel deleted scenes
playlist including how Black Widow almost
came back from the dead.
Thanks for watching and hope you have a marvellous
movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!